trying to communicate to this this to
the guy I'm like you know it's like my
hair kind of underneath here you have to
trim it or I'll get like these clown
edges and he goes yeah yeah and just
goes
and I'm like
uh uh but uh and I go that's not what I
said and so you'll see on my special
dark pale that my hair wait this is the
haircut you got this is this special and
so the hair the trainee I look at you
know
during the edit I'm just like
can you guys do something with the hair
and I'm like she's that hair looks bad
so you'll look at it and I'm like good
God that's forever too and I was
ridiculous yeah and so it's just it just
you'll just see it and you'll go guys
can't wait to watch this now his hair
looks like
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler